salut salut les séries la pointe de la
musique un merci salut salut les
confiner ces locaux fini au les confiner
et on est enfermé et on peut pas faire
le marché et notre mère nous a saoulé et
on est confiné et à tous ces couacs au
cocon confient les cocons qu on est
confiné et on va tous et sous les saluts
chéri bon aujourd'hui je suis tout seul
regardez j'ai préparé plein de trucs il
ya de l'action vérité qui va arriver on
a plain d'image on a de tout vous avez
vu que maintenant je me suis fait un
micro sans fil salaires suis comme ça là
on est dans la technologie
c'est parti on est là j'ai les tweets
ici j'ai les caméras la g est ce qu'on
va faire
ici j'ai plein de trucs merci d'être
aussi nombreux alors regardez on est
bien sûr en direct et j'ai mis le
jogging jogging spécial marché bien sûr
avec les poches pour rendre la molette
attaque c'est parti nous qui quittent
bons les chéris déjà ya beaucoup de gens
qui me demandent ce que deviennent les
chroniques eh ben j'ai des nouvelles des
chroniqueurs je vais vous dire tout de
suite déjà ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ya pas mal de gens qui me
demandent des nouvelles de kelly et
bastien john kelly elle va bien elle
s'est relancée dans la chanson regarder
[Musique]
voilà où il fait des bisous voilà elle a
l'air d'aller bien les cherry on me
demande aussi des nouvelles de mathieu
mathieu quétel à hier mon chéri gilles
aussi cette semaine
aujourd'hui on a décidé de laisser au
repos mathieu et gilles voilà parce que
on veut pas prendre de risque au
charisme et chérie voilà aujourd'hui je
serai seul jeu vous lancer plein d'image
on va faire plein de débats y aura du
facetime n'aura des stars et bien sûr je
vous le dis restez chez vous les chéris
c'est important très important j'ai
plein d'infos n'aura dit me mohamed en
face time aussi dans un instant si vous
avez des questions si vous avez des
questions posées n'hésitez pas si vous
les classes de l'action vérité aussi
n'hésitez pas alors mathieu et ben
mathieu clairement depuis hier ça va
plus trop regarde
[Applaudissements]
mais question voilà bon battu on espère
que ça va aller mieux mon chéri mais
déprime pas inquiète pas tu as un beau
balcon tu as un truc très bien on a des
nouvelles également béchir on a des
nouvelles d'isabelle mon isabelle
d'amours moniz à belmont et duboscq on a
des nouvelles machines et il avait l'air
d'aller bien
elle a trouvé un nouveau délit a regardé
j'ai vu du ciel bien je sens que ça va
vous faire kiffer sarsgaard
[Musique]
bon c'est ce qu'on appelle le 1 2 3
culotte à 2,3 culotte 1 2 3 q la toile à
isabelle je fais des gros bisous on va
l'avoir en face time isabelle dans un
instant fait style à mon avis elle se
fasse sur son be bop on va voir si on
peut lui installer un petit truc mais
normalement on va pouvoir faire un gros
dos il ya beaucoup de réactions
concernant mon tapis
ouais j'ai retrouvé ça je me suis dit ça
fait sympathique wassa mais l'ambiance
était un petit peu de rose on veut voir
la vie en rose aujourd'hui parce que
c'est vrai que c'est la nasse eu mes
chéris on a des nouvelles également de
du cousin de gilles verdez on n'a pas pu
avoir il demanda des nouvelles de son
cousin et bien je peux vous voyant lui
il est bien il est dans son arme
tranquille en garde les hollandais ne
ressemblait à aucun des humains qu'ils
avaient rencontrés jusque là bas mais
ils ont quand même eu une impression de
déjà vu
les hollandais l'auront fait penser à ce
singe
voilà la lourdeur c'est notre vie c'est
le cousin de gilles voilà qu'on embrasse
et très bon reportage hier ça sur france
5 et plus et ayant un bon tiers j'adore
france 5 on est des nouvelles aussi de
valérie bénaïm elle a passé une petite
tête dans un jt en israël ont regardé
valérie bénaïm l est pas mais les
colères les colères mais les dark a
quand même solide en mêlée c'est avoir
la forge colborne et cette nouvelle
coupe
un pont du l'élu va très très bien à
l'ailé tu tiens un truc ma chérie tu
tiens un gros gros délire on a des
nouvelles de maxime kenny aussi mes
chéris barak singly ben je vous dis hein
il perd pas le moral maxime gainey il
est dans son délire et maxime gagné il a
décidé de faire un truc de faire un
petit peu de business
pendant ce confinement pendant cette
crise ducobu de 19 ans regarde
et
[Musique]
gros bisous au maximus ou maxime gagné
vous manque et les chirurgies en tout
cas j'espère vous retrouver vite en tout
cas j'ai pas envie de retrouver tout de
suite tout de suite même si je les aime
bien c'est quand même
benjamin castaldi parce que benjamin
castaldi va regarder il n'a pas changé
confinement ou pas ils changent pas le
garder